why now it's the football it was like
having a massive family oh we want is
just a club to support they know the
death that we feel what is a football
club who is it for in the shadow of the
famous Manchester clubs in the northwest
of England berry for 134 years berry
Football Club was there for the people
of the town they were feared by their
rivals and drew big crowds twice they
won the famous FA Cup they're giggling
ground is now deserted the club close to
death mismanagement from their owners
largely to blame that's the business
football has become the Northwest of
England is one of the most important
areas of world football some of the big
premier league clubs Liverpool
Manchester City Manchester United are
all from this area in fact I might get
20 Football League clubs that's about a
fifth of the Football League come from
the Northwest of England of course it's
19
with the demise of Barry I think
football is just it's a working-class
sport for us and it always has been it
was formed in the mills if you couldn't
afford to go to the games as a lot of
people couldn't it didn't matter because
you could still chat to your mate on the
corner of the street going hey did you
see what happened did you read it in the
paper you know I don't think people
understand unless you're a football fan
what it is like to then lose that
Gaussian playing fields they've ice
early and still dream of a goal of win
maybe a career in football Barry
under-17s are playing little borough
[Music]
volunteers still providing time and
support for young players working with
Barry's Community Trust this was the
idea that he'd bring them through the
ranks but that's been taken been taken
away from them which is a shame on the
other side of town for a different age
group walking football the community
work of Barry FC continuing Keith's
Maddock is one of the people keeping it
alive now the job it does is absolutely
vital there's a lady who who tweeted me
and their parents went to a thing called
sporting memories whichever piece which
is something we do with people with
dementia Alzheimer's etc just over there
by the social club and she said it's
almost keeping the mum and dad alive the
AFL and the Premier League gave us given
us our funding until the summer now
they're going to continue beyond all
James Bentley watched his first Barry
game aged seven with his father
23 was he's lucky Gate he wrote two
books on Barry teams who were able to
take the field at giggling I miss this
place with everything in my being at the
moment the I now I don't look forward to
the weekend I do a five-day working week
Monday to Friday 9 to 5 in an office and
previously you'd be sitting at your desk
thinking at least I've got the football
to go to this week I might not be having
a good week where I've got a game to go
to now I don't have that though fans
still come together could Barry rise
again a phoenix club somewhere down the
league's but alive we don't want to be
in the situation again where we're
relying on individuals who are promised
in the earth if they're not actually
delivering you have hope in there
somewhere but if I keep on but got to
keep going this is why we do these fans
meet ups at weekends this is why we stay
at the Phoenix club we've got a keeper
man ticking even though we might have a
club as if more in time we will be
Barrett
we are various funds our Barry the
controversial owner during the
liquidation process Steve Dale has
stayed away from the town and would not
respond to our questions the English
Football League who expelled the club
says it will review its procedures but
told UK government inquiry
responsibility lies with the owners of
Barry
fans from many clubs have left scarves
and messages of support former England
manager Bobby Robson once said what is a
football club not the buildings or
directors or people who represent it
it's the noise the passion the feeling
of belonging the pride in your town who
owns your football club and what do they
intend to do with it which club which
town is next to suffer the way Barry has
Lee Wellings al Jazeera in the town of
Barry